le rapport sauvé est un rapport qui je
pense va constituer des lignes de
travail des lignes force de travail pour
les pour les mois et sans doute les
années à venir l'ambition de la
commission sauvé des groupes de travail
c'était 2-2 de voir les difficultés dans
lequel se trouve l'exercice de la
justice dans toutes ses composantes
le rapport sauvé en fête commence d'une
certaine manière par
une conclusion implacable puisqu'il
parle de délabrement de la justice c'est
quelque chose d'ailleurs que l'on vit au
quotidien dans nos juridictions tous les
jours nous constatons également
cesser ces petites absences et petites
difficultés ou ses plus grosses
d'ailleurs qui mises bout à bout rang de
travail du quotidien extrêmement pénible
quelquefois c'est tout bêtement le matin
en arrivant les magistrats qui ne
peuvent ouvrir leur ordinateur les
sessions prennent 30 minutes pour
s'ouvrir parce que le réseau est saturé
parce qu'il ya une difficulté etc
[Musique]
je pense que ce qui est absolument
nécessaire c'est de faire la chasse aux
temps inutile c'est à dire les temps qui
sépare la prise de décisions par exemple
sur l'orientation d'une procédure et son
passage effectif devant la juridiction
suite à la ce qu'on a appelé la tribune
en fin d'année 2021 le président du
tribunal judiciaire et moi même avons
souhaité créer au sein de notre
juridiction un groupe de réflexion sur
les conditions de travail au sein de la
juridiction versaillaise tout ceci
aboutit en fait à un certain nombre de
propositions environ une soixantaine que
nous avons soigneusement
répertoriés avec monsieur le président
certaines sont liées aux conditions
matérielles d'autres c'est sûr par
exemple les temps d'audience nous avons
souhaité répondre avec monsieur le
président puisqu'il a déjà des choses
qui sont engagés
[Musique]